[Musique]
comme moi vous ne voudrez pas que ce
soir ce soit un match
ne garde coque
ni perfidie mondaine elle est utile au
débat la une de paris match avait gros
je pense que c'est le sait pas du tout
utile au débat je pense qu'on doit
évidemment faire la distinction entre
vie publique et vie privée lequel a
décidé d'expulser 5 millions de français
musulmans de ce pays pourquoi pas 10
pendant que vous y êtes parce que ils
sont cinq cabon et que ce sont des
français qui donc danguel goody qui n'a
pas commencé hier soir et l'a twitté son
dégoût il faut croire que je commence à
inquiéter suffisamment pour que paris
match le caniche du pouvoir essaye de me
nuire vous êtes en danger pour notre
pays vous avez une vision rabougrie de
la france vous êtes un raciste vous avez
été condamné pour ça vous êtes un homme
qui professait une vision de la virilité
extrêmement curieuse extrêmement
violente c'est vous qui écrivez que les
femmes sont le butin des hommes chacun à
l'habitude dans les campagnes
présidentielles de voir des boules
puantes nous nous avons décidé de ne pas
laisser ces boules puantes atteindre et
regin j'ai mis cette arme à distance
parce que je n'ai rien à voir avec tout
ça je ne veux pas qu'on dise que en
définitive les idées serait une
apparence que nous combattent riom pour
la forme les idées sont sérieuses notre
position est totale à eric zemmour 1 en
soi mais non enfin franchement eric
zemmour qui vient hystériser le débat
politique
oui je crois réellement que vous dites
vous avez été trotskiste je vous
rappelle les titres les les textes multi
je vous rappelle qu'il a massacré
je vous rappelle que vous avez été
communiste et vous avez été socialiste
il m'avait dit en mars vous savez moi
votre vie quotidienne des français je
m'en fous ce qui m'intéresse c'est le
grand remplacement est grande et
classement mais moi je peux dire je suis
très fier ne pense exactement le
contraire vous êtes dans une impasse
intellectuelle la france que vous voyez
n'a jamais existé la grandeur de la
france a tenu à ce processus là et ce
processus j'y suis attaché la
créolisation n'est pas un choix c'est
une réalité aujourd'hui jean-luc
mélenchon y va je pense qu'ils en ont un
peu en manque
de visibilité médiatique
et là ça va lui redonner beaucoup de
visibilité médiatique monsieur zemmour
nous serons nombreux à ne pas vous
laisser faire vous ne chasserait pas les
musulmans vous ne les obligeraient pas à
choisir entre l'islam et la france c'est
pas un affrontement style brune 1000
yens vous avez une vision de la
politique une vision spectacle c'est un
affrontement de fond touche entre deux
visions de la france l'assimilation ça
veut dire faire sienne l'histoire de
france la culture française les moeurs
françaises ça veut dire devenir français
s'habiller comme les français donner un
prénom français à ses enfants sciemment
jean luc mélenchon il veut profiter de
la bulle médiatique
de d'eric zemmour pour peut-être
relancer sa campagne la délinquance que
nous vivons n'est pas une délinquance
c'est un jihad
c'est une guerre qui nous ait mené une
guerre de civilisation
une guerre de pillage une guerre de vol
une guerre de viol ou c'est la force des
rixes et quoi c'est qu'il est vraiment
sincère ce qu'il dit le pense vraiment
et il le pense tellement qu'ils doivent
ya des des compromis qui devrait faire
par rapport à la répression par exemple
un débat les prénoms il ya des conflits
il les fera pas jamais parce que ses
années aux log vous ne règlerait rien
vous pousser les gens à l'affrontement à
la guerre civile ça n'a aucun sens vous
êtes tellement provocateur que vous avez
été vite à provoquer les gens sur leur
prénom parce qu'il portait le prénom du
prophète mais vraiment quel os x ou
débattu ce soit en particulier
mélenchon a trahi mélenchon mélenchon
suis des électeurs mélenchon essaye de
courir à des électeurs parce qu'il
allait arriver mais voilà je vous le dis
non je ne pense pas que je vais regarder
je pense qu'on aura un pugilat
en essayant de donner l'idée que vous
allez les caniches is et vous n'y
arriverez